so this is the new iphone 6 and you
already know the big news
it's bigger
that's because apple has actually
increased the size of the display almost
by an inch which bumps up all the other
dimensions of the phone as well except
one the iphone 6 is thinner by almost a
millimeter and that's actually pretty
important because as you make a phone
larger you really need to make it
thinner so you can hold it comfortably
in your hand thanks to that slimness and
the new rounded edges of the phone the
iphone 6 is easy to hold is it as
perfectly engineered for my palm as an
iphone 5s
probably not but the difference isn't
really all that big and you do get a
much larger screen as a result that
screen by the way is bright and colorful
and fast it allows you to read more see
more you can even add an extra row of
apps on the bottom of the home screen
it's a real improvement
now with the old iphone even someone
like me with small child like hands
could get their thumb to reach every
corner of the display that's a little
bit harder on the iphone 6 but apple
does have a new trick called
reachability and it helps a lot all you
have to do is double tap the home button
and the top portion of your screen
slides down making it easier to reach
it's fast and simple and i picked it up
as a habit within a day another change
that apple made was the location of the
sleep wake button it used to be on the
top but now they've moved it to the side
so it's easier to reach
internally the iphone 6 has a new
processor a new co-processor and a bunch
of other technical mumbo-jumbo that you
don't really need to care about suffice
it to say it works really well one
feature you do want to pay attention to
available storage has now doubled to 128
gigabytes so if you're the kind of
person who likes to take a lot of photos
and videos shoot away
the iphone 6's battery has improved but
not by leaps or bounds you might pick up
an extra hour or three over an old
iphone 5s which is kind of disappointing
considering that the 5s was already
getting dinged by some for having
lackluster battery life
every year apple improves the cameras
and its phones and this here is no
exception the iphone 6's new camera can
focus faster and shoot even slower
slow-mo bottom line if you haven't
gotten rid of your dedicated
point-and-shoot camera or camcorder by
now
the iphone 6 might make you
so should you get one
yeah
if you're coming from an old iphone the
jump in screen size alone makes this a
worthwhile upgrade if you're coming from
android well you've known about larger
screen phones for years but now that
apple makes one you have one less reason
to choose android over ios and i happen
to think ios is the better of the two
apple may have resisted making a large
screen phone for a while but now that
they have
they might have made the best one yet